let's go back to this like Field of
Dreams tip if the biggest lie that was
ever told us yeah okay so there seems to
be this prevailing myth that exists that
film a filmmaker excuse me can build an
audience using social media and make a
living where though does this audience
come from if they don't even have a film
yet you know they say well get that
audience going then start making your
film include them in the process but at
this point there's so many people doing
it do you think that that's real do you
think people can rely me not everybody's
Kevin Smith not everybody's louis ck you
can just put up a paypal thing and well
get donation let's be really clear about
the louis ck correlation louis ck is an
overnight sensation 20 years in the
making louis ck decided he didn't want
anybody to inter mediate his career and
therefore from the very beginning he was
building a direct relationship with his
audience right his ability to now sell
out of his own website came from a
20-year dedication and he turned down
money that he could have taken when he
could have taken a deal we're sort of
somebody else was responsible for the
audience and kept his career smaller for
a while because he wanted the direct
relationship he wanted to own the
pipeline the whole time that takes a
tremendous amount of integrity and hard
work and and a real desire for
independence and the fact is like not
everybody actually wants an independent
career I would just like us to stop
treating independent filmmaking as the
calling card to the studio system I
don't think that's what it is because
that's not independent if you want to
build an independent career you
absolutely have to dedicate yourself to
actively engaging your audience who is
your audience well I like to start here
right we do this in the class that we
teach all over the country which is we
ask someone in the audience to give us
the the logline and short synopsis of
the film that they're thinking of
crowdfunding and they give the brief
synopsis and I look around to the crowd
and I say who else in here would be
interested in seeing that and without
fail ten hands go up and those people
don't look the
saying they don't belong to the same
demographic and I say okay now I want
you to ask these people where do you
hang out online what times a day are you
online on those platforms what kind of
news do you do you look at what kind of
music do you listen to what kind of
blogs do you read if any blogs what do
you do in your free time do you belong
to any organizations any alumni groups
where'd you go to school what makes you
click when you click and most
importantly where do you watch stuff
when you watch it so the information
that you start to gather there lets you
get really specific about how to spend
your energy because where do you get
most of your recommendations for film
from your friends right so you always
start with the core group of people who
are actively interested in seeking out
new content that are actively interested
in seeking out the kinds of things that
you're making and you turn them into
amplifiers over time but it starts by
joining the conversation and you know
what it might mean we can't make
meaningless drivel anymore it might mean
that we actually have to make stuff that
like busts through the doors and says I
have arrived do you know what I mean
like all of this year's breakout
performance films at the Gotham awards I
think all of them were crowd funded and
it felt like love and dear white people
and a girl walks home alone at night
those are movies that literally kicked
the doors open and said I am here and
you have never seen anything like me so
I just I think it has to come from a
deep desire for independence hard work
and patience and there's a video that's
been circulating that some big comedians
like Reggie Watts and stuff got involved
with that said they want a no funding
platform called work harder and I
actually while it was very funny it
really miss understands what it takes to
successfully crowd fund and let me be
clear if you are a film artist
you are always crowdfunding all of your
funding no matter whether it's people
buying tickets at the box office or
downloading your movie or giving you 25
bucks to get your film off the ground in
the earlier stages it's all crowdfunding
and it all takes the same tools of
identifying that audience activating
them getting them excited getting them
to tell their friends at every stage of
your film career so crowdfunding has you
know popped up as this word of the thing
that we've needed to be doing all along
right we've just figured out a way to
pull to actually make money marketing
our films before we've even made them
you